no nos va a tomar mucho tiempo darnos
cuenta de que si tomamos potencias cada
vez más altas de un binomio y las
desarrollamos se vuelve cada vez más
complicado pero bueno vamos a
desarrollar algunas cuantas potencias
del binomio para que veas qué tan rápido
se vuelve enredoso así es que pues vamos
a comer un binomio
este es un binomio porque tiene estos
dos términos y bueno vamos a elevarlo
primero a la potencia cero a ver qué
pasa aquí si tomamos cualquier número
distinto de cero y lo elevamos a la
potencia cero pues nos queda simplemente
un 1 cierto bueno ahora entonces vamos a
tomar nuestro binomio y lo vamos a
elevar a la potencia 1 así es que nos
queda simplemente
además ve muy bien hasta ahorita no ha
sido nada enredoso pero vamos a ver qué
pasa con nuestro binomio pero ahora
elevado al cuadrado si no has estado
practicando eso de elevar binomios al
cuadrado entonces seguramente has estado
tentado a escribir a cuadrada más de
cuadrada pero no es así eso está muy mal
y si hiciste eso deberías sentirte
ligeramente pero muy ligeramente
arrepentido esto no está bien a más b al
cuadrado no está cuadrada más b cuadrada
es simplemente nuestro binomio por otra
vez nuestro binomio ok y a la hora de
desarrollar esta multiplicación lo que
nos queda es aportar
a cuadrada más
por ve que es a por ve más ve ahora que
pues en realidad se escribe como otra a
por ve más y finalmente ve por ve que es
una de cuadrada ahora estos dos son
igualitos entonces los podemos poner en
un solo término y nos queda a cuadrada
más tenemos dos de estos dos a b más b
cuadrada más de cuadrada bueno tampoco
estuvo nada complicado no sin embargo
ahora vamos a desarrollar a más p al
cubo y te recomiendo que lo pongas pausa
y los saques tú solito
este binomio al cubo es igual
a más de elevado a la segunda potencia
por otra vez el binomio a más de y para
hacer esta multiplicación pues vamos a
hacerlo de una forma más fácil vamos a
poner por aquí
+ d
y vamos a hacer esta multiplicación de
esta forma y vamos a poner de verde
cuando multiplicamos por esteve y
entonces nos queda de x b cuadrada pues
es de kubica más de por 2 a d
2a ve cada vez más ve por a cuadrada
pues es a cuadrado por b y vamos a
escribir con rosa lo que multiplicamos
por ésta
a ver tenemos aquí una ave cuadrada y la
multiplicamos por a y nos queda aprobé
cuadrada entonces ponemos por aquí o por
be cuadrada más
2 ave por una y nos queda dos a cada
lado por b y finalmente a cuadrada por a
es simplemente a al cubo
y ahora simplemente tenemos que sumar
todos estos términos
entonces nos queda de al cubo de alcohol
más 2 a de cuadrada más otro de estos
adecuadamente así es que nos quedan 3 de
ave cuadrada y aquí tenemos pues 3 a
cuadrada probé no porque tenemos aquí 2
a cuadrada por b más uno de a cuadrada
por b y eso es 3 a cuadrada de más 1 x
al cubo a al cubo y mirad apenas a estas
alturas pues ya nos tomó una cantidad
considerable de tiempo en desarrollar
este binomio al cubo y la cosa sólo se
va a seguir poniendo cada vez más
complicada o sea ahora imagínate
desarrollar el binomio a la cuarta
potencia y bueno ni siquiera tiene por
qué ser nada más a la cuarta potencia
ahora imagínate cómo se va a poner la
cosa cuando estemos desarrollando el
binomio
décima potencia oa la veinteava potencia
como que si se pondría algo complicado o
no y aquí es donde se vuelve súper útil
el teorema del binomio a ver pero que
ese sobre el teorema del binomio tenemos
que repasar lo
rima
de él
mi novio vino mío y bueno me voy a
quedar con la anotación de ahí ve lo que
tenemos es por aquí un binomio que está
compuesto de a más
he elevado a la potencia m y lo que nos
dice el teorema del binomio es que
elevar este binomio a la enésima
potencia es igual a la suma y bueno la
anotación y la fórmula se van a ver un
poco complicadas al principio pero
después lo van a entender mucho mejor
cuando veamos un ejemplo concreto el
chiste es que es la suma desde que cae
es igual a cero hasta que cae es igual a
n estã n y está en eso en la misma d ha
elevado a la potencia n - k por b
elevado a la k por un coeficiente que
vamos a repasar en unos cuantos segundos
que son las combinaciones de n estã n en
k que es el valor que toma esta acá en
este sumando entonces las combinaciones
de n en cada a las que también nos
referimos cuando estamos hablando acerca
de las formas de escoger de un conjunto
de elementos
elementos
son un objeto de combinatoria muy
utilizado en las matemáticas y es igual
a n factorial / k factorial x
m - k factorial y bueno entonces vamos
ahora a ver este ejemplo del que estaba
hablando con números concretos y por qué
no empezamos este ejemplo con este
binomio que nos estaba dando miedo
desarrollar o sea con
a más ve a la 4a ver esto es igual y
ahorita voy a usar tal cual esta
anotación esto es igual a la suma desde
que acá es igual a cero hasta n que en
este caso es un 4 de las combinaciones
de 4 en cada x a la 4 menos cada golpe a
la k y bueno esto a que es igual pues
podemos desarrollar esta suma y lo que
nos queda pues es esto suman 2 pero
sustituyendo cada una de las casas entre
0 y 4 o sea que aquí vamos a empezar
sustituyendo acá igual a cero así es que
el primer término son las combinaciones
de 4 en 0 x a la 4 - 0
o sea simplemente a la 4a a la 4 y ya me
voy a quedar con el puro naranja para no
estar cambiando tanto de color entonces
a a la 4 x b a la k pero que hay cero
entonces aquí sería vea
cero que es uno entonces podríamos poner
por aquí un 1 pero pues mejor lo dejamos
así no más el segundo término de esta
suma que son las combinaciones de cuatro
en cada cuando cada vale 1 x a la 4 - 1
o sea a la 3a a la 3 por ver a la 1 o
sea simplemente ve más este término
cuando caes igualados o sea las
combinaciones de cuatro en dos por a a
la 4 - 2 o sea a al cuadrado a al
cuadrado por ve a la 2 o sea b al
cuadrado nada las combinaciones de
cuatro en tres por a a la 4 - 3 o sea a
la 1 a por b a la 3 o sea ve al cubo
ahora si finalmente las combinaciones de
cuatro en cuatro por a la 44 pero eso es
simplemente a la 0 que es un 1 por b a
la 4 o sea simplemente ve a la 4 y
entonces ya casi terminamos ya lo único
que nos falta es encontrar cuánto valen
estas cosas de las combinaciones de n en
que no querías y es que pues encontremos
las
a ver vamos a empezar por este que son
las combinaciones de cuatro en cero y
pues tenemos aquí que eso es simplemente
4 factorial que es nuestra n entre cada
factorial que es 0 factorial por n menos
k es 40 factorial y pues 4 -0 es
simplemente un 4 y lo estamos haciendo
factorial entonces pues sabemos que el 0
factorial es simplemente un 1 y aquí
tenemos 4 factorial entre 4 factorial
eso es simplemente un 1 entonces las
combinaciones de 4 en 0 son simplemente
un 1 entonces vamos con este por aquí
estamos buscando las combinaciones de 4
en 1 está fórmula nos dice que las
combinaciones de 4 en 1 es n factorial
que es 4 factorial entre cada factorial
qué es
factorial por n me queda factorial que
es 4 - 1 factorial pero 4 - 1 es
simplemente un 3 y le tenemos que poner
factorial y para simplificar esta
fracción hay que recurrir a la
naturaleza de los factoriales esto de
aquí el 4 factorial es simplemente 4 por
3 por 2 por 1 y este 3 factorial es 3
por 2 por 1
entonces pues se ve que ahí se van a
cancelar algunas cosas no a ver vamos a
escribirlo 4 factorial es 4 por 3 por 2
por 1 y aquí tenemos 1 factorial que es
un 1 por tres factores que es 3 por 2
por 1
entonces esto se cancela con esto y nos
queda simplemente un 4 entonces las
combinaciones de 4 en 1 son simplemente
un 4 ahora vamos a sacar las
combinaciones de 4 en dos combinaciones
de 4 en 2 es igual en el factorial 4
factorial entre cada factorial 2
factorial por n menos que sea 4 menos
dos que simplemente otro 2 factorial y
esto es igual
4 factorial es 4 por 3 por 2 por 1 y 2
factorial es 2 por 1 pero pues 2 por 1
es simplemente un 2 entonces de este
factorial tenemos este 2 por este 2
factorial que es otro 2 y pues estos 2
12 se cancelan con este 4 y nos queda
simplemente 3 por 2 y 3 por 12 6
entonces las combinaciones de 4 en 2 son
iguales a 6 ahora sacamos las
combinaciones de 4 en 3 a ver esto es
igual a 4 factorial entre 3 factorial
por 4 menos tres factorial que es un 1
factorial te suena conocido pues qué
bueno que si no suena conocido porque
mira 4 factorial entre 3 factorial por 1
factorial es justo lo que sacamos por
aquí
ok es igual a las combinaciones de 4 en
esto ya vimos que es igual a 4 entonces
las combinaciones de 4 en 3 es igual a
14 entonces ya nada más tenemos que
sacar las combinaciones de cuatro en
cuatro combinaciones de cuatro en cuatro
4 factorial 4 factorial entre 4
factorial 4 factorial por cuatro menos 4
que es un 0 factorial y otra vez esta
cuenta ya la habíamos hecho antes está
por aquí lo único que tenemos que hacer
es cambiar estos dos factores de lugar y
listo ya son iguales así es que ya
sabemos cuánto valen las combinaciones
de cuatro en cuatro
valen uno las combinaciones de cuatro en
cuatro son iguales a uno y tal cual
acabamos de terminar vamos ve a la 4 es
igual a 1 x a la 4 más 4 x al cubo por b
más 6 x al cuadrado b al cuadrado más 4
x a por ve al cubo más 1 por ver a la 4
y listo
a ver además ve a la 4 es igual a la 4 a
la 4 más 4 voy a poner los coeficientes
con morado 4 x a al cubo por ver más
por la cuadrada por ver cuadrada más
44 podrá volver al cubo más 1 por ver a
la 4 o sea ve a la 4 y listo como que
quedó muy bonito muy simétrico hasta hay
muchos patrones ahí en medio y todo no o
sea empezamos con la 4 y vamos bajando
la potencia aquí tenemos a la 3 y
tenemos a la 2 aquí esto es a la 1 y
bueno aquí no está escrito pero
podríamos pensar que tenemos un 1 que a
piña al cabo es como un a la 0 y lo
mismo con la b o sea empezamos con b a
la 4 y vamos bajando el exponente de
derecha a izquierda entonces tenemos ve
a las 3 y ve a la 2 y ve a la 1 y luego
por aquí tenemos un de a la 0 muy bien
escondido y también podemos cambiar de
lugar y ponerlo por aquí y los
coeficientes como que también siguen
cierto patrón no o sea tenemos por allí
4 luego el coeficiente del término de
enmedio que son 6 y luego se repiten del
centro hacia la orilla otra vez los
coeficientes o sea aquí tenemos este 4 y
aquí tenemos otra vez un 1 y esta es
sólo una aplicación o bueno un ejemplo
del teorema del binomio pero hay
muchísimos y en los próximos vídeos
vamos a ver varios de estos ejemplos del
teorema del binomio y en algún punto
vamos a tratar de entender por qué
funcionan